สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนนักเรียน
ครูเรียมวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 24
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนสิงหาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ 2565
[เพลง]
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ค.ศ 2022
แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ตอนนี้ 9 โมง 29 นาทีค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะกินข้าวเรียบร้อยแล้วค่ะครูหญิงกิน
ข้าวหรือยัง
ผู้หญิงกินข้าวแล้วค่ะเพราะว่าผู้หญิงก็
ประมาณ 4 ทุ่มครึ่งก็ต้องกินข้าวแล้วเนาะ
จะนอนแล้ว
ใช่เรียมก็ถามครูหญิงตลอดเลยว่าครูหญิง
กินข้าวหรือยังกินข้าวหรือยังเพราะว่า
เรียมก็ลืมว่าผู้หญิงอยู่ที่อเมริกา
แล้วอเมริกาตอนนี้ก็ประมาณ 4 ทุ่ม 4 ทุ่ม
ครึ่งกลางคืนใช่ไหม
อิ่มแล้วพร้อมนอนแล้วค่ะจะหลับแล้วค่ะไม่
ได้
ครูหญิงจำได้ไหมว่าคลิปที่แล้ว
เรียมง่วงนอน
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่ให้เตรียมนอน
ใช่
เพราะว่ากูจะต้องมาเล่นเกมกับผู้หญิงก่อน
ไง
ใช่ในคลิปนี้ครูหญิงง่วงนอน
เรียมก็ไม่ให้คุยหญิงนอน
เอาแล้วจะให้ผู้หญิงทำอะไรอ่ะค่ะไม่ให้
นอนผู้หญิงต้องมาเล่นเกม
เล่นเกมเล่นเกมอะไรคะครูเรียมต้องใช้
ไอคิวเยอะไหม
ต้องคิดๆๆมากๆเลยค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะต้องคิดคิด
มากๆ
ผู้หญิงจะเล่นได้ไหมเนี่ยต้องคิดๆมากๆ
เนี่ย
ไม่เป็นไรเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวมาดูกันว่าผู้หญิง
จะลองดูได้หรือเปล่า
ได้ค่ะแล้วเกมต้องเล่นยังไงคะครูเรียมเกม
นี้เตรียมจะมีรูปภาพให้ผู้หญิงดูค่ะ
แล้วก็จะให้ครูหญิงบอก
ว่าในรูปภาพนี้มันมีความหมายว่าอะไร
[เพลง]
ให้ทายคำจากรูปภาพอ่ะหรอคะใช่ให้ทายคำจาก
รูปภาพแต่ว่าในภาษาไทยเนี่ยคำบางคำคำ
หนึ่งคำมันอาจจะมี 2 ความหมาย
[เพลง]
สิ่งที่เห็นกับสิ่งที่ต้องตอบออกมาอาจจะ
แบบอาจจะต้องคิดๆๆเยอะๆ
ได้ค่ะลองดูการเรียนจะบอกว่าอุ๊ยผู้หญิง
ไม่รู้จักภาษาไทยเลยเป็นกูได้ยังไงเนี่ย
เล่นเกมหมดชั่วโมงแล้วนะนักเรียนจะบอก
มาลองดูลองดูครูหญิงพร้อมนะคะ
แฟ้มค่ะ
พร้อมแล้ว
ดูในรูปภาพค่ะ
รูปภาพก็จะมีอาหาร
แล้วก็มีโจร
ใช่ไหมมีโจรมีตำรวจเดี๋ยวครูเรียมรูปนี้
เนี่ยกี่พยางค์บอกได้ไหม 1 พยางค์ 2
พยางค์ 3 พยางค์รูปนี้มี 2 พยางค์
2 พยางค์
อะไรกันเว้ยหยุดนะ
2 พยางค์หรอใช่หยุดนะ
หยุดจาน
มีคำว่าจานหวานไม่มีไม่มีคำว่าใจ
อย่าลืมจะใบ้ให้นิดนึงว่าเวลาที่เรากิน
ข้าว
เราก็จะมี
มีข้าวแล้วก็จะมีของหวานแล้วก็จะมี
ข้าว
กับข้าว
กับดัก
ไม่ใช่หรอถูก
ผู้หญิงรู้ได้ยังไง
อันนี้รีบกลับด่าง
ก็นี่ไงคะอันนี้เป็นกับข้าวใช่ไหมก็คือ
กับกับอย่างเดียวแล้วแบบมันกำลังดังโจร
เอาไว้ไม่ให้โจรเนี่ยวิ่งไปได้ไงก็คือดัก
หน้าใช่ไหมเวลาที่แบบเราเดินๆๆแล้วมีคน
เข้ามาแบบสวัสดีครับแบบขอคุยด้วยหน่อย
เนี่ยเขามาดักหน้าเราแต่ว่าอันนี้ไม่ใช่
คนไงเป็นกับข้าวนะคะก็เลยเป็นคำว่ากับดัก
ใช่แต่ว่าถ้าเกิดเอาคำว่ากลับข้าวกับดัก
แบบเหมือนโจรมาดักๆที่จะแบบเอาเอา
โทรศัพท์เอาเงินของเราใช่ไหมคะแบบหยุดๆๆๆ
อันนั้นคือดังแต่ว่าถ้าเอาคำว่ากลับกับ
ดาบมารวมกันเป็นคำๆเดียวเป็นแบบ
ใช่มันจะเป็นอีกความหมายนึงนะ
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงก็จะคิดว่าแบบว่าคำว่ากลับ
ดาบเนี่ยนักเรียนก็จะคิดถึงเวลาที่เรา
เดินอยู่ในป่าเนาะแล้วเสร็จแล้วเราเดิน
เราตกลงไปแล้วก็เป็นเขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะมี
ตะแกรงอ่ะเราอยู่ในตะกร้าเป็นตาข่าย
ตาข่าย
เป็นกับดักตาข่าย
[เพลง]
เวลาเราคิดถึงนะคะ
มันไม่มีรูปอ่ะ
หรือว่าคนที่แบบ
คนที่แบบ
ไปล่าสัตว์น่ะผู้หญิง
แบบค่ะพี่เขาถือปืนเข้าไปในป่าใช่ไหม
แล้วบางทีเขาก็แบบทำกับดักไว้ให้สัตว์มา
ตกลงในกับดักของเขา
จะขุดหลุมขุดหลุมขุดหลุมแต่ก็เอาใบไม้
เนี่ยโปะเอาไว้ไม่ให้รู้ว่าเป็นหลุม
แล้วเราบางทีเราก็ได้นะหรือว่าสัตว์เดิน
ลงมาแล้วมันก็จะมีตาข่ายอยู่อยู่ในหลุม
ใช่ไหมคะเพราะสัตว์เดินลงมาก็ตกลงไปแล้ว
ตาข่ายมันก็จะจับเราก็จะขย่อง
หรือว่าครูหญิงเคยดูหนังไหมดูหนังแบบที่
ตำรวจจะไปจับจับโจร
ตำรวจจะไปจับโจรแล้วทีนี้ตำรวจก็คิดว่า
เอ๊ะ
ทำไมถึงหาโจรได้ง่ายจัง
กับดักหรือเปล่า
กับดักของโจรใช่ไหมว่าแบบว่าให้
จับผิดจนก็หนีไปได้หรือว่าโจรให้ตำรวจ
เข้าไปในบ้านหรือว่าตึกตึกนึงแล้วก็
ระเบิดตู้ม
ก็เป็นกับดักเนอะใช่เป็นกับดัก
นี่แหละ
ผู้หญิงเก่งมาก
ๆคิดนานๆ
มีอีกไหมคะครูเรียมเริ่มรู้สึกแบบพลังมา
แล้ว
ต้องแบบยากๆ
มาค่ะ
มีผู้ชาย 1 คนแล้วก็ผู้ชายที่ใส่ผ้า
ขาวม้าอ้วนๆใช่ไหมนั่งอยู่แล้วก็มีผู้ชาย
ใส่เสื้อสีเหลืองเนี่ยเหมือนเขากำลังสัก
แล้วก็ข้างหลังก็มีเหมือนผู้ชายผู้หญิง
เป็นแฟนกันแล้วก็สักเหมือนกันอันนี้กี่
พยางค์คะครูครูเรียมมี 3 พยางค์
3 พยางค์ถูกมีคำว่าถูกไหม
มี
ถูก
ข้อ
ข้อถูกถูกทุกข้อ
[เพลง]
ถูก
ถูกทุกข้อเพราะว่ามันจะมีเห็นไหมเขาจะ
สัตว์คำว่าถูกเนี่ยเครื่องหมายถูกนะคะไว้
ตรงข้อสอบข้อมือ
ข้อเท้าแล้วก็หัวเข่าก็เป็นข้อเหมือนกัน
ก็คือมีถูกอยู่ทุกข้อทุกข้อของร่างกายเรา
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงจะเล่นเกมได้ถูกทุกข้อไหมคะนัก
เรียน
เนี่ยมีเกมมาให้ครูหญิงเล่น 10 ข้อแล้ว
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยถูกถูก
ตอบถูก 10 ข้อเลยผู้หญิงก็ถูกทุกข้อไม่
ผิดเลย
เก่งมากนะไม่มีใครทำได้นะคะใช่เก่งมาก
[เพลง]
นักเรียนตอบได้ไหม
โอเคมีอีกค่ะไปรูปต่อไป
กระดาษทุกตัว
ตัวละ 5 แสนจ้ะ 90,000 ทุกชิ้น
อันนี้เนี่ย
ตรงแผงขายเสื้อตรงนี้ก็มีคนใช่ไหมถือ
เหมือนเขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะโทรโข่งแล้วก็เสื้อ
บอกว่า 10 บาททุกตัวมีคนมุงเยอะๆส่วนอัน
นี้เนี่ยบอกว่าเสื้อตัวละ 5 แสนแล้วก็
ข้างหลังเนี่ย 90,000 ทุกชิ้น
กี่พยางค์คะครูเรียม
2 พยางค์ค่ะ
2 พยางค์
มึงมีคำว่ามุงไหม
ไม่มีค่ะไม่มี
แพง
ไม่มีไม่มี
อันนี้ยากจังเลยอ่ะ
เสื้อ
ไม่มีนักเรียนช่วยครูหญิงหน่อยเร็ว
นักเรียนช่วยครูหญิงหน่อยได้ไหม 2 พยางค์
2 พยางค์ 10 บาททุกตัวถูก
มีคำว่าถูก
ถูก
ใจถูกกาง
ตา
ถูกถูก
พยางค์ที่ 1 หรือพยางค์ที่ 2 บอกได้ไหมคะ
เป็นพยางค์ที่ 2 ค่ะ
[เพลง]
มีใครคิดได้ก่อนคือหยิ่งบ้างมีใครคิดแบบ
นี้มีนักเรียนคิดออกแล้วหรือเปล่านัก
เรียนครูหญิงทำไมผู้หญิงยังคิดไม่ออก
อ้าวร้านถูก
เรียกถูกไม่ใช่
ไม่ใช่เขากำลังทำอะไรกันอยู่
ขายถูก
ซื้อถูกไม่ใช่อ่ะมันง่ายไปอ่ะดูถูกถูก
ต้อง
พรุ่งนี้ก็ไม่คิดจะคำว่ามองคำว่างงดูถูก
เพราะว่าคนเนี่ยมาดูเสื้อที่ถูกใช่ไหมไม่
มีใครไปดูเสื้อที่แพงเลยขอบคุณค่ะครู
เรียมใช่
แต่ไม่มีใครซื้อนะดูอย่างเดียวมันดูอย่าง
เดียว
แต่คำว่าดูกับคำว่าถูกเวลาที่มันเอามารวม
กันความหมายมันก็เปลี่ยนนะคะการ
ดูถูกเนี่ยอันนี้ไม่ดีเนาะดูถูกก็คือผู้
หญิงก็อาจจะบอกว่าสมมุติครูเรียนมาบอกว่า
คุยๆหญิงคุณเรียนอยากจะสอนอะไรดีล่ะกูยัง
อยากสอนอะไรดีคะ
เดี๋ยวจะสอนอะไรดีอ่ะ
อยากจะสอนร้องเพลงสมมุติสมมุติ
อย่ามาดูถูกเรียง
ก็คือแบบดูถูกก็คือพูดหรือว่าคิดว่าคนคน
นึงน่ะ
ไม่เก่งไม่ดี
หรือว่าแบบว่า
ดูครูเรียนแต่งตัวดูเสื้อสิดูแบบ
ดูเป็นคน Low  Class มากเลยอ่ะมาเรียนที่
โรงเรียนนี้ได้ยังไงเนี่ยเรียนนี้เขามี
แต่ลูกคนรวยนะ
ดูการแต่งตัวซะถือกระเป๋าแพงและดูนี่สิ
ไม่อยู่ได้ไงเนี่ย
ผู้หญิงทำไมดูถูกคนอื่นแบบนี้ล่ะ
เพราะผู้หญิงเป็นคนนิสัยไม่ดีนะคะ
อันนี้สมมุติ
อันนี้คือการดูถูกใช่ไหมคะอาจจะแบบเขาทำ
ไม่ได้เขาไม่เก่งแล้วก็เหมือนกับรู้สึก
ว่าแบบเขาไม่เท่ากับเราไหมแล้วก็จะบอกว่า
ดูถูกเหมือนครูหญิงเคยได้ยินไหมคนที่แต่ง
ตัวแบบแต่งตัวไม่ดีแล้วก็เข้าโชว์รูมรถจะ
ไปซื้อรถสปอร์ต
แล้วคนขายก็แบบ
คนขายก็คิดแบบ
เออไม่มีเงินน่ะแบบ
เพราะว่าแต่งตัวไม่ดี
คนขายถูกว่าแบบ
ไม่มีเงินแต่งตัวแบบนี้มีเงินซื้อหรอ
ใช่
เหมือนแบบว่าผู้หญิงเคยแบบมีมีเหมือนพี่
เมื่อก่อนนะคะเขาไปเดินร้านขายของที่เป็น
กระเป๋าแบรนด์เนมอ่ะผู้หญิงจำไม่ได้นะ
ยี่ห้ออะไรแล้วเขาก็กำลังหยิบอยู่อ่ะค่ะ
หยิบดูอ่ะแล้วมีพนักงานอ่ะเดินมาบอกว่า
แพงนะคะ
แพงนะคะเหมือนแบบว่าคิดว่าเขาไม่มีเงิน
ซื้ออ่ะเห็นไหมคนขายหรือว่าพนักงานก็ดู
ถูกคนนี้คือเขาจะมีเงินหรือไม่มีเงินเรา
ก็ไม่มีสิทธิ์ที่จะพูดใช่ไหมอ่าเป็น
พนักงานขายทำไมดูถูกลูกค้าอาจจะมีเงินก็
ได้ใช่หรือว่าถ้าเกิดเรียนแต่งตัวดีๆนะก็
ไม่ใช่ว่าเรียนจะมีเงิน
ใช่ค่ะคุณอาจจะไม่ได้ดูถูกก็ได้นะคะ
อันนี้คือคำว่าแพงนะ
แต่งตัวเฉยๆ
ใช่
นั่นแหละก็อย่าไปดูถูกใคร
โอเคผู้หญิงเก่งมาก
ครูหญิงจะตอบได้ถูกทุกข้อไหม
ถ้าผู้หญิงตอบถูกเรียนจะมอบมอบงูให้เป็น
ของรางวัล
ผัดกระเพราหรอ
คะ
งูก็ไม่ได้ถูกนะคะครูหญิง
โอเคๆครูหญิงพร้อมไหมคะข้อสุดท้าย
พร้อมค่ะพร้อมค่ะพร้อมโอเคไปดูกันค่ะ
เดี๋ยวขยาย
นักเรียนก็จะมีห้องใช่ไหมแล้วก็มีเด็กๆ
เด็กๆกำลังดูทีวี
ที่ทีวีเนี่ยมีได้
แล้วก็อันนี้ก็เป็นพ่อของเขาน่าจะพ่อพ่อ
ก็ดูทีวี
แต่ว่าทุยมีตัวดีอยู่
ครูเรียนมีกี่พยางค์คะบอกก่อนได้ไหม
ยาวแน่ๆเลยอ่ะ
เสร็จ
[เพลง]
พยายามนักเรียนข้อที่ 1 เนี่ยมี 2 พยางค์
ใช่ไหมข้อที่ 1 เนี่ยกับดัก 2 พยางค์มัน
โอเคนะข้อที่ 2 มี 3 พยางค์ถูกทุกข้อ
ข้อที่ 3 มี 2 พยางค์
ดูถูกข้อนี้มี 7 พยางค์
แต่ว่าครูหญิงต่อเร็วมาก
การบอกว่าง่ายมากด้วยไงแล้วพอครูเรียนพูด
เจ็ดพยางค์เนี่ยนะเด็กดูได้ผู้ใหญ่ดูดี
7 พยางค์ถูกไหมคะเด็กกำลังดูได้แต่ได้
เนี่ยเขาเขียนแบบนี้นะ
เวลาออกเสียงนะคะออกเสียงเนี่ยเหมือนกัน
เด็กดูได้
แต่ว่าเสียงมันจะเหมือนตัวนี้
เราก็ผู้ใหญ่ดูดี
เพราะว่าพ่อเนี่ยหรือว่าผู้หญิงแล้วก็ครู
เรียนเนี่ยเราเป็นผู้ใหญ่แล้วเราไม่ใช่
เด็กๆผู้ใหญ่เนี่ยดูทีวีที่มีคำว่าดีตัว
ดีอยู่นะคะก็คือเด็กดูได้ผู้ใหญ่ดูดี
หูมันมีความหมายว่าอะไรคะผู้หญิง
เด็กดูได้ผู้ใหญ่ดูดีก็คิดว่าเขาน่าจะพูด
ถึงพวกรายการทีวีหรือว่าหนัง
ซีรีย์ที่มันเป็นพวกเหมือนแบบ Family
Show นิดหน่อยไหม
มันดูมีความเป็น
ครอบครัว
ใช่ไหม
[เพลง]
ไม่ใช่แบบทีวีโชว์ทุกอันนะที่เด็กดูได้
บางอันที่แบบ 18+ เด็กก็ดูไม่ได้นะ
ใช่
แล้วนะคะใช่อันนี้เขาหมายถึงแบบเป็นสิ่ง
ที่เด็กก็ทำได้เด็กดูได้ผู้ใหญ่ก็ดูดี
ก็คือผู้ใหญ่ก็ดูได้
แล้วก็สนุกเหมือนกันครูเรียมคิดว่าถ้า
เป็นครูเรียมครูเรียมคิดถึงรายการอะไรแบบ
เด็กดูได้ผู้ใหญ่ดูดีรายการบางรายการ
เรียมก็ดูกับแม่นะตอนที่ยังเป็นเด็กๆอยู่
ริมก็ชอบดู
แล้วแม่ก็ชอบดูนั่งดูทีวีด้วยกัน
เนาะเออเหมือนเราเด็กๆเราจะแบบพวกแต่งงาน
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยเกมเศรษฐีใช่ไหมมีคำถาม
แล้วก็เลือกคำตอบมีคำตอบ 4 ข้อนี้มาเล่น
กับคุณเรียมดีกว่าอาทิตย์หน้าแล้วเหมือน
เราเป็นคนได้เงินเองนะเราแบบนั่งดูอยู่
หน้าจอทีวีแล้วเหมือนแบบ
ฉันต้องตอบให้ได้ฉันต้องได้เงินรางวัล
แต่ความจริงก็ไม่ได้
แบบสนุกมากนะคะก็คิดว่าเป็นรายการที่ผู้
หญิงรู้สึกว่ารายการพวกเนี้ยเด็กดูได้ผู้
ใหญ่ดูดีก็คือแบบเด็กก็ได้ใช้ความคิดคือ
คิดด้วยกันน่ะเล่นด้วยกันมันก็สนุกดีนะคะ
นี่ก็เป็นผู้หญิงก็ถูกทุกข้อใช่ผู้หญิง
ถูกทุกข้อขอบคุณครูเรียมนะคะที่ใบ้ให้ผู้
หญิงก็เลยถูกทุกข้อแต่มีข้อสุดท้ายนี่
แหละที่เร็วมากใช่เร็วมากนักเรียนก็ยัง
คิดอยู่เลยว่าคืออะไร
แต่บางคนก็เก่งนะก็จะอาจจะตอบได้แล้ว
ใช่ค่ะโอเคเนาะก็นักเรียนน่ะถูกทุกข้อไหม
ก็คอมเมนต์บอกเราได้นะคะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้
เนี่ยผู้หญิงกับครูเรียมก็ไปก่อนเนาะแล้ว
เดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้านะคะใช่
ค่ะสวัสดีต้องลาไปก่อนค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
บ๊ายบาย